love this man i would say it even if
he's not sitting here i do say when he's
not sitting here as well uh the host of
uh first take on espn and stephen a's
world on espn plus as well as
somebody who is lighting up the nba
coverage on espn pre post and halftime
great to see you soon it's great to see
you how are you doing i'm doing better
for seeing you yeah how are you feeling
i'm doing great man i feel great this is
you know you know i went through the
whole cover thing i always appreciated
you checking in on me thank you so much
of course and of course your lovely wife
who's been my friend for over 20 years
you can't forget susie can't forget her
okay but um i appreciate y'all checking
up on me but i'm feeling a lot better
man it was a rough goal of it but i'm
feeling a lot better it was a rough goal
oh yeah no question about it i mean they
told me you know thank god i was
vaccinated so i don't try to you know
push people to get vaccinated or
anything like that everybody's got their
own beliefs but i think that we all know
it's a global pandemic going on we know
how serious it is we know that there's a
virus out there and wearing the mask
certainly helps matter so at least say
that and that's what i try to do well
it's great to have you back in the mix i
missed you when you were gone and now
you are back and it is great to see you
michael irvin didn't miss me but that's
a different subject you know what no no
that's not a subject a subject for
but it was kind of fitting though that
you know you came back just in time yeah
it was just it was it was such a
beautiful time it wasn't it i mean
i mean i was just touched i mean the
lord was looking out for me i mean for
me to be gone for a month and then after
more than 30 days off the air which has
never happened in my career for my first
day back to be
right after the cowboys lost
it was very touching i mean it was
special
i'm going to hold on to that memory for
a long long time well um you know i was
planning on working into this but we're
just gonna get right to it you know the
gentleman around your right shoulder tj
jefferson you've spoken to him before
yeah um you like that brother i i i do
too yeah and i don't know if you could
see you can see it on the screen
you could see you see that velvet rope
that he is attached in between the two
golf bags it's right there in front of
him uh that velvet rope is there to uh
create a club that he's got right here
was the club okay here's the club uh
would you put it up on the screen please
um this is a club that he has created
because so many people were calling in
to try and argue with him about the
dallas cowboys that there's tier one
you're allowed in the club if you have
three or more super bowl wins if the
team that you root for has three or more
super bowls do i get this right that's
right they are in vip with us they're in
the vip they're in the vip you know how
that works steven they i know you've
been to the club maybe you know what i'm
saying you come through the back
you cut the line yeah you know how it is
i'm at a point where it's all vip yeah
i won't accept anything
i won't get it
i tried to tell rich that you would
understand this right
there's other criteria though for others
whereas like if
if their super bowl team has one or two
wins you're in the club zero wins you
have to wait in line and if they've
never been you you you can't even be
stephen
never made the super bowl right then on
friday night don't bother that outfit
that you picked out take it back to the
store
that layaway you had cancel it don't
take the shower
peacock and chill don't call an uber
airlift
but make
you know i say that stephen a smith let
me tell you something rich for weeks
said that you were going to come in here
and crap all over this but i told no
stephen a smith understands because
stephen a smith is the type of man he's
got so many people coming at him for
what he says right and time is money
stephen that's right
time is money you can't waste time just
like talking to everybody so you have to
like prioritize who you are
the stephen a smith argument or stamp to
and that means some people like if you
carolina panther fans want to talk to me
you ain't never won like you can say
something about the cowboys
it's been so long since his team has won
it's true it's true you like right there
in that category with him
so it's not like you can stick out your
chest and act like especially because
i i mean i had an afro
you know last time i mean my headline
was about two feet forward i mean it's
been a while but but i want to be i want
to take this day
to move on from the cowboys in this
respect i want to say this because
jordan lewis for the cowboys i heard he
said something disrespectful about me
you know he's caught up in his feelings
i want to say first of all first of all
jordan lewis i understand i understand
why you're miserable
i really do i just want to say that
with all of that being said it's all
love it's all fun it's my moment okay
i'm going to troll cowboy fans i will
not stop
i know
that they're going to have their moment
i'm the same guy that will roll up in
arlington right down the block from att
stadium and watch the game with cowboys
i would i have taken first take to their
territory
it's all in fun i actually respect the
hell out of the cowboys organization
jeremy jones on down it's just that your
fan base is so annoying stop it that it
pleasures me that y'all lose there's
nothing against jordan lewis there's
nothing against demarcus lawrence who's
had some b for me in the past there's
nothing against dak ezekiel or anybody
else it's your damn fans if they shut
the hell up and stop bothering me on the
streets white black old young
middle-aged hispanic asian american i
mean the list goes on how about them
cowboys well how about them
how about them
how about them
let's move on
see rich i tried to tell you i knew
stephen nate was a closet cowboys fan
cowboy just now i'll never be a cowboy
fan i just respect the organization but
i just love when y'all are miserable i
mean to know that y'all some of y'all
bought round trip tickets to sofa
and they're non-refundable i coaxed
michael irvin and they're telling them
to buy number five
they lost their money in the game it's
beautiful to me christmas
later than christmas it's a beautiful
thing stephen a smith here on the rich
eisen show okay so we could turn the
page on the cowboys let's talk about um
some other topics in the nfl
starting with uh today's uh news that
i'm sure dominated your show sure what
are you what do you make of brian flores
things um i applaud him for bringing
attention
to the issue and
potentially ruining his career as an nfl
coach see we talked about colin
kaepernick making the sacrifice this is
a sacrifice okay
colin kaepernick listen god bless him he
was an individual that could play grab
you know guided to san francisco 49ers
uh to to the super bowl we know what he
brought to the table and we know
ultimately what he ended up sacrificing
uh but he was taking the position and he
was still playing and then they got wind
of it and it became you know you know
just dominated the news airlines the
news airwaves rather and things of that
nature in the headlines and
things just regressed from there
in the case of brian flores
you're interviewing for the new orleans
saints job you are interviewing for the
houston texas job you're considered a
finalist for both of those jobs
but yet because of what happened to you
with the giants and what happened to you
allegedly when you were talking to
stephen ross the owner of the miami
dolphins and he is talking to you about
throwing games and he'll pay you a
hundred thousand dollars per loss if you
lost on purpose and he's bringing up
john elway and his gm and how they came
to a meeting disheveled an hour late
looking a bit inebriated and what have
you and you highlight
the situations that black coaches in the
national football league have had to
endure
for him to step up at this moment in
time in his career when everybody knows
he didn't deserve to be fired from miami
it didn't appear to make any sense
whatsoever he did a damn good job with
them over the last two years it just
seemed to be uh just something that was
incredibly courageous on his part for me
i want to know more details but i will
say this in a hundred years the giants
have never hired a black coach
that's incredibly incriminating and i'm
somebody that'll never root for them
because of that and i'm a native new
yorker
um
you look at steven ross with his rise
organization and his philanthropy when
it comes to black causes and the
millions upon millions of dollars he's
dedicated i would tell you i have a
totally different imagery of him now
than i would than i did prior to this
class-action lawsuit that's being thrown
at him
because when you go up to a black coach
in his first time in his first you know
time at this in this position
and you tell him you want him to lose on
purpose and you offer to pay him to lose
i'm sorry rich eisen if it's found that
that is true
this is the nfl's version of donald
sterling he's got to go
you can't have an owner that literally
is offering a coach money to lose games
on purpose
that is incredibly damaging to the
integrity of the league i want to
emphasize if it is proven to be true
these are allegations we do not know but
it's proven to be true and then again as
a black man i'm a little bit different
than a lot of folks from this respect to
from this perspective
racism exists
but i know
and i've always told white america this
there's a difference between systemic
racism
and pointing at an individual and saying
you're racist
i happen to believe there's plenty of
white folks that i know that are not
racist i don't believe it i see them
they're god-fearing people who work hard
just like everybody else okay but when
you're talking about the system
that's where african americans
all over this country have a case
because we continue to see
evidence upon evidence upon evidence
where no matter what is told to us
we're judged by a different standard
we're treated we're treated differently
and it's almost never equally
and the fact that in the year 2022
we have one african-american head coach
19 years after the rooney rule was
instituted in 2003 in which we had three
black coaches we've actually taken a
step backwards
how can anybody excuse that
it's just that simple so then that's my
follow-up is what is your expectation
level of the change that could
come out of this i think that brian
flores bringing this case is going to
bring into question anti-exempt laws
that the nfl has had in its favor
um i think it's going to bring attention
to the fact that you don't have
any black ownership within the national
football league any black majority
ownership because everybody ain't jerry
jones and robert craft everybody doesn't
you know own their team lock stock and
barrel and you know you most nfl teams
you have a multitude of partners why
can't you have a multitude of black
partners why can't one of those black
individuals have a majority stake in the
franchise there's a lot of money out
here there's black folks with money and
you could find that you haven't let
people into your club i think ultimately
that's going to change and i think once
that changes i think we will go a long
way towards making progress we've got
billionaire owners billionaires for
every in case you don't know
billionaires don't like to be told what
to do they're usually telling people
what to do okay um but in this
particular instance
when you hurt their pockets which is
potentially the case they will make
change keep in mind when a whole college
happening situation was going around
the owners and i always bring this up
every owner pocketed one year 246
million dollars you know this from the
television deal
and they still complained
because colin kaepernick cost them
anywhere from 15 to 20
of the money that they could have gotten
according to numerous reports
so if they were complaining back then
imagine the kind of damage this could do
to them particularly if nfl players
stand up and make some noise especially
if nba players join in
think about muhammad ali think about
what he went through but think about who
was standing behind him jim brown nfl
bill russell
nba correspondent
kareem abdul-jabbar nba kurt flood and
these guys major league baseball it
wasn't just guys from the world to
boxing
there were black athletes from all over
the place who stood up imagine if that
happened now
and it's entirely possible with the
advent of social media with the reach
these dudes have with the fearlessness
that they
they put on display time and time again
and with the brotherhood they have with
each other
just to bring attention to the lack of
equality that's taken place in the
national football league do not rule out
the possibility that some serious noise
could be made to provoke change if you
wanted to do it with social justice
issues as i said on numerous occasions
george floyd was a metaphor he saw the
cop with his knee on his neck
i was saying black folks have felt for a
long time as if we've had that
proverbial knee on our necks
for a long long time
and we're tired of it and this is an
opportunity if you're professional
athletes if you stood with arms locked
to in unison with one another to fight a
good fight this is right in your
wheelhouse this is a sports issue it's
more than that but it's definitely a
sports issue so the people out there in
the political world and what have you
that says just play sports or whatever
you can't say that now because this has
everything to do with sports and
athletes i think can stand up and if
they choose to stand up and [ __ ] and
make some noise
nfl owners are going to have major major
problems well i mean they could also uh
a team could also hire brian flores
that's right because he's an outstanding
coach who's proven what he can do uh in
the league already well you're right
you know and and also um you know
we we talk all the time about a coach
being
needing to be a leader
and also stand for something and be
somebody who has a philosophy i mean
we pretty much have seen this guy's
willing to stand up my only retort to
that would be this rich
just because he gets hired as a coach
doesn't mean the lawsuit goes away
he does if you watched him on his
interviews this morning he doesn't seem
like an individual who is going away
it's almost like the nfl messed with the
wrong dude he's walking into this
situation assuming it's going to cost
them he could have waited to see whether
he's going to get the new orleans or the
houston texas job right he didn't do it
he said bump that i'm sick of this and
not only am i sick of this i'm sick of
this on behalf of a multitude of my
brothers within this industry that are
experiencing this and as a result he
asked for class action lawsuit so you're
talking about him inviting others to
join with him to bring attention to this
so you've got all of that working
against you
if you are the owners and i emphasize
the owners because where i disagree with
some people
it's hard i understand that the nfl had
to be mentioned in the law in the
lawsuit i get that because obviously
they implemented the rooney rule and
because people are not
circumventing the rooney rule you have
to mention the nfl okay and and you and
you know they're not going to get
through a summary judgment you're going
to have to go and address this you're
not going to be able to shove this aside
i get all of that
but i also look at the diversity within
the national football league office i
also look at an executive vice president
like troy vincent who has spoken out
about the actions of the owners and i
think that the nfl league office could
easily separate itself from the actions
of the owners the only mistake i think
they made was when they said the nfl and
our clubs in their statement they
should have said the nfl they shouldn't
have said they should never mention
those other words in our club oh no no
no you ain't got anything to do with the
miami dolphins the new york giants the
denver broncos in other words i'd have
threw them out to pasture just by not
mentioning them we the league office we
think this lawsuit is
meritless as it pertains to us and i
know they can't because they answer to
the owners so i'm not being facetious
but i'm just saying it would have been
if they had done if they had been able
to do something like that it would have
been beautiful because that's exactly
what should have happened especially
since troy vincent was quoted in the
lawsuit that's right that's right he was
in he's in the lawsuit yeah i mean so he
was quoted publicly in the washington
post plus he came on stephen a's world
on espn plus and basically reiterated
his comments about the things that need
to be done by these owners but he also
emphasized how the effort there's no
shortchanging the effort that the nfl
itself has put forth in trying to
address this issue and that is why i
don't condemn roger goodell i don't
condemn roy troy vincent i don't condemn
anybody with the league office i'm
looking at individual billionaire owners
that are sitting there probably saying
excuse me roger goodell you work for us
you like the salary you make and that's
cause we pay it to you shut the hell up
and do what you're told that's the
attitude towards the commissioner and
the league office i think you have a
plethora of of owners within the
national football league that feel that
way and that is what roger goodell is
battling so i support roger goodell in
the nfl more than most they're not
perfect and there's some things that i
definitely disagree with but by and
large i do think their efforts have been
uh there as it pertains to this issue
stephen a smith here in studio i
remember
being in the office
the day after stuart scott
was
imitated on saturday night live
and there is no greater i think right
measure of somebody's success
than if you are sent up on saturday
night live and the fact that you were i
thought chris redd
kind of
kind of took care of you or you know or
what what do you think
well first of all i think he's
phenomenal right he's a phenomenal
talent
i think he did a better job of imitating
mayor
adams the new york the new man
that to me i mean that was spectacular
television
he was good with me but i thought jay
farrow who used to be on saturday night
live right did me a bit better see you
know i thought he did me a bit better
you know
i do you know frank listen i've been
imitated by frank caliando scott van
pelt
uh imitated me one time with tony
kornheiser and mike wilbon on pti
asked him to play me doing the masters
it was hysterical it was many years ago
but it was hilarious okay but
that guy keenan thompson doing michael
irving
now that was spectacular that was that
was an exact the line where he said that
god can't didn't talk to him because he
doesn't have one of these and held up a
supernova oh he was the boy he said
excuse me
god is wrong
jesus this is hilarious it was
hysterical it really really was you know
i i mean listen listen are you ready for
this i posted i i've been blessed and
fortunate enough jimmy kimmel i was
honored he allowed me to host his show
yes uh one night and i had an absolute
blast because i want to do late night
someday in my future that's all my
bucket list i really want to do it you
know what else is on my bucket list one
day what is it it's a whole saturday
night live let's go let's start it i'm
going to do it one day
i'm a big enough name i think i'm a big
enough next stephen i mean this will
happen i think
we're we're
we're part of that crew
to help you this is going to happen
hashtag steven a for snl yes i
appreciate it
i'm not as good to look at as kim
kardashian
i'm not as good to look at as as as a uh
oh my goodness i forgot oh my goodness
it's the singer who's a katie katie katy
perry yes yes i'm not as good looking as
them i know that but but i i i think i
have the potential to make people laugh
i think you've got the chops you can
handle it you've got the platform well
the biggest point is it's in new york
city yeah where am i from of course
where am i from i used to watch i used
to work at the barnes and noble's
bookstore on 48th and 5th avenue right
around the corner from saturday night
live making 435 an hour that's amazing i
think steven smith here so you you
uh you used to work at a barnes noble
when did you work at obama i was in
college at fashion institute of
technology before i went before i went
to winston-salem state so i would work
at the barnes noble's bookstore as a
book clerk traveling from queens a hour
and a half because you got to take the
bus to the train so it takes an hour and
a half to get from queens to midtown
manhattan run up the block work at
barnes noble from 8 30 a.m to four and
then at four o'clock i had to race
across town run no no uber nothing like
that existed at the time i had to run
from 48th and fifth to 27th
and and between 7th and 8th avenue to
get to practice basketball practice for
fit by 4 30
then i had to do those two hours before
i had continuing education classes from
6 30 to 9 30 every night for a year and
a half before i left and transferred on
a basketball scholarship to
winston-salem state okay so there's two
follow-up questions here yes first one
uh first one is how how were you selling
books like where did you
book clerk i mean what happened is
somebody came up and asked you
fetch it for you and bring it back to
you i'd organize everything to make sure
that when people came into the bookstore
they knew exactly where at what area
they needed to go to get their i paid my
dues rich
man the other one who's like the fashion
institute of technology basketball
listen man we had um thomas edison high
school was where i played basketball my
senior year and we had a tournament at
fit i was coming off the bench i was
never a starter but that was one of my
better games i had 27 points that game
right so i had twice a little it was a
rarity i ain't trying to front an act
like that
okay but i had 27 points that day and
the coach marvin rippy at the time who
was an exceptional coach i appreciated
him more later than i did when i was
playing for him because he was a
disciplinarian but he was a fabulous
fabulous coach and he came in there and
and you know offered me a partial
scholarship to come and play at fit
because i was five nine 135 pounds
soaking wet wasn't any college you know
recruiters coming my way not for
division one so i went there okay and
you know i got to tell you it wasn't bad
i mean listen
i majored in advertising and
communications yeah all right so i was
able to transfer those credits to
winston-salem state for mass
communications but here's the deal and
i'm not knocking you know i'm you know
i'm conservative with my money i'm a
fiscal conservative with my money i
can't stand paying taxes i pay too many
taxes in new york and california i need
to to move to a tax-free state from
crying out loud but i am liberal in my
thinking so i live and let live all i'm
going to tell you is this
95
of the school
were women
and
you know because it was it was fashion
and then you have a lot of folks from
the gay community that would go
to f.i.t you know they there were some
of them there so basically
most of them even most of the population
in regards to heterosexuals was the
basketball team
it was a very lovely
a party and it was like a party on this
on the school yards because it's only
like a block long or whatever but they
had us and it was like
maybe
400 people at the party
maybe 50 guys
i mean
why'd you transfer it it was attractive
it was it was really nice it was really
nice i transferred because i want to get
high get away from home okay i want to
get away from home i wanted to be you
know i want to go to a four-year
institution get a full basketball
scholarship where i went to play for
clara's big house games
but i went on campus
now this is division two just to show
you how how how things could be could
you imagine you see the big money in
college sports now right yeah well it
wasn't that big money in division two
but when i got to winston-salem
on my recruiting trip yeah i had two
female escorts
to show me around campus
but i had beautiful escorts
they were
fooling and so
i just looked at winston i was like
what's the curriculum
you said you got you got mass
communications don't you you don't got
math communications don't you yeah i'm a
basketball scholarship my education's
free yeah
so i get to play basketball and be here
and i'm good i'm good and now you're a
mass communicator of the first variety
stephen a yeah right here on the rich
eisen show steven a's world on espn plus
first take every single day uh okay so
this is kind of going to be by the way i
have such a blast on your show yeah man
she did great that was so nice
well it was just a blast
we had to have you this is one of the
things that i want to say yeah you know
i've been very blessed and fortunate to
achieve what i have achieved and i'm
grateful incredibly grateful to espn for
all that they've done for my life
but it doesn't happen without you
dan patrick
keith olbermann chris berman stewart
scott
john saunders god rest both of their
souls i love them dearly i was very
close to both
dick phyto
so many others man i mean you know y'all
built the place and that's why you know
sometimes you just see people from time
to time when somebody leaves espn and
folks are just you know they say what
they say and all of this other stuff and
i'm like
y'all don't get it we we love y'all you
know y'all we understand
y'all built the damn place well i
appreciate you would you throw me in
with that that mix you know and and i
was there for seven years it's
incredible i met my wife there my kids
are espn babies so to be invited back
out there you know uh on that on the
show was great i know it was a surprise
to you but we knew from the start of the
season you were coming on i'm like he's
coming on there's no way i'm gonna have
to deal with michael irvin every monday
night
it was just a blast so uh now that
you're here i'm gonna give my version of
this closest thing we do to debate and i
usually debate myself coming up with an
idea um chris brockman you have how many
uh items do you have over there we have
six we have three nfl and three
basketballs okay let's do it what's more
likely with steven a smith here on the
rich eyes and show hit it hit it
[Music]
what what's more likely never say never
but never there you go that's our uh
our production value that's it that's
never productive okay all right guys
what's more likely who's more likely
they just played an epic afc divisional
round game
more afc championships in the next five
years chiefs or bills what's more likely
what do you think stephen bills
i would ah
i'm concerned that the day ball's gone
man i i i that i wonder i wonder if that
if that if that's gonna hurt him for at
least one year
oh gosh i'll i'll go the other way just
to just uh just to say something else
please of course comment go for it i
respect david last four years offensive
coordinator and buffalo did a damn good
job even though sometimes i thought he
was a bit predictable with the with
going away from the running game and
just throwing the football and not
presenting any running game whatsoever
having said that i wish him luck i think
he's going to do a good job with the new
york giants i think his credentials are
there and i can't knock that right for
giving him the job even though i don't
like with the whole flores thing
josh allen
is a star he's no doubt a star and i
know patrick mahomes is a star too but
you've been to four afc championship
games in a row all of them on your home
turf you've gone to two super bowls one
one lost another but the last two times
the last the last two times i mean we
saw you in the players but you got
shellacked by tampa
and then this time around you got held
to three points by cincinnati in the
entire second half and over time
i think there comes a point in time
where your time is your time
not to say that tyreek hill and travis
kelsey are over because i still think
they got time i just think the footsteps
of the buffalo bills are coming
and i think as a result of that
i i see josh allen
um i see him being a dude again we can't
dismiss joe burrow either because he's
in the super bowl for chronicle i
honestly thought that would have been
the what's more likely just allen or or
burrow
but but this is not a this is a terrific
one in its own self yes i can't argue
with that i can't argue what else you
got over there chris what's next jimmy g
talked yesterday he's on his way out of
san francisco said he wants to go to a
winner so which quarterback is more
likely to end up on a winner
jimmy g or deshaun watson
well i think desean watson number one
because john de sean watson is more of a
winner himself than jimmy g and as a
result of that um since you're the
quarterback you're going to dictate your
winning ways
jimmy g is not a scrub
he can play
but he's not that difference maker i
don't care what the record says before
you think about him you thought about
the defense you thought about debo you
thought about kittle and you thought
about kyle shanahan's play calling what
quarterback do you know that i'm
thinking about four to five layers of
things before i even get to you kirk
cousins
something i'm not sure because i don't
think you can say all of that about him
i could look at dalvin cook sure i
thought about him justin jefferson
jefferson now okay right okay i'm not
thinking about their defense or zimmer
before i think about kirk cousins
that's by default because i'm thinking
about kirk cousins getting that money
and never winning just trying to think
of somebody who might be in that
category i don't think jimmy g's gonna
start next year how does that sound i
think he's going to start wherever he
goes i just don't think it'll be san
francis obviously wherever he goes he's
not gonna be in san francisco i think he
starts i just don't think he's the guy
that's going to deliver you a super bowl
with deshaun watson when desean watson
is on that field yes it's the first
thing you think about you think about
him
you don't think about you you know t you
know jjy was there and and and you know
he has some weapons and deandre hopkins
right but you thought about deshaun
watson correct jimmy g
hell i might think about me before i
think about jimmy g
i just don't think about it and i don't
even think like i said i don't i don't
know i know that the niners are working
with somebody to or working with him to
try and find a spot for him i honestly
don't know who's gonna say you're our
starter or right or or take him out he's
the best case scenario is he's going to
be taking on and being a competition for
him to try and win something else but
let me take something back
i don't think about jimmy g except for
when i'm in california
when i'm in california i remember what
he was doing when he came to this part
of california which is why i call him
porn star jimmy i do think about it from
time to time when i'm here in l.a i
actually drive by that place
okay guys breaking news the bengals are
playing the rams in the super bowl thank
you very much i heard about it who's
more likely to make it to the super bowl
next year in arizona the rams of the
bengals i'll i'll take the bengals in
that one so would i
i would i am so all in
on joe burrow and as a matter of fact
the thing that i like about burro and
his chances more than the rams
i think that bengals are about to start
dominating this division what do you
think about that i'm i'm a steelers fan
so i don't want to wish that i know that
but i think that has got to get a
quarterback if he gets a quarterback
with the weapons he has available to him
i think that they could say something
about that and lamar jackson to be
healthy i think he could say something
about that right but there's no taking
this away
joe burrows a star second year in the
league first full season in the league
got you to a super bowl jamar chase is a
star
and the fact that you got those two
with joe burrow leading the way
i i can't
i can't i think this is i listen i'm not
making my pick yet but i'm giving the
rams a good chance to win this game yes
but i do believe it's probably the only
super bowl they're going to get to oh
well
how about this one then let me retort
instead of being as strong as saying i
think the bengals are about to dominate
the afc north which team would you
rather be the star quarterback in the
nfc west or the afc north well i would
rather be the afc i'm a competitor
so i want the stiff competition to be
the man i'm a rick flair fan the nature
boy
to be the man you got to beat the man
today and there's a whole bunch of men
up in the afc and mahomes allen lamar
jackson all of these dudes with borough
with justin herbert who i'm a huge fan
of okay
in the nfc i don't know where aaron
rodgers is going to end up tom brady
just retired drew brees is gone so the
path
uh the the road to prosperity is
significantly easier it appears in the
nfc
but i'm not interested in being the tall
dude in the small man's contest
with me with giants and let's get it on
that's me but i understand that
everybody might not think that no i
understand that but if you're just
taking a look at what's an easier path
to getting definitely on the game and
trying to get through right right it's
definitely an nfc well i i don't know
the afc north i i i need to see what the
ravens look like with lamar back and
they got to sign him long term and i got
to see what the steelers look like and
you're questioning the browns right now
they quo they took a step back well sure
i i knew they were going to take a step
back they could make fields in that dude
he had more progressive commercials than
wins i kept telling everybody that okay
let's call it what it is now now i
respect his talent i don't think he's a
scrub but he's not that dude jimmy g is
not a scrub but he's not that dude what
do i mean
okay
it's on the line
here's the ball take media see that's
the beauty of covering basketball as
much as i do
you knew
what the great ones kobe shack
michael jordan the list goes on and on
you knew what they were gonna do we
still know what they're gonna do at some
point in time in a basketball game they
say
this is what we're gonna do this is who
the hell is gonna do with what you're
gonna do about it you got to stop us see
in football so much is schematic right
that's why i love burro and jamar
because with burro and jamarti like this
is what we're gonna do two-man game is
how we gonna do it yeah what you gonna
do about it i mean when you think about
i think it was a tennessee game correct
me from wrong
not only did joe burrow throw like the
first seven or eight passes to jamal he
didn't even look
at t higgins or anybody else even look
at him he went he kept his eyes right on
your ball he was like this is what we
gonna do
here's how we gonna do it
what you gonna do about it and when you
see that
in football
that is special because that's guys
saying i'm superior to you and there's
nothing you can do about it yeah the
first jamar chase had the first big play
of that incredible week in a 57 yarder
what else you got over there uh they
played last night in the nba yeah
stephen a chris paul and james harden
who's more likely to win an nba title
first
no i was willing to say james harden
because i'ma believe in the golden state
warriors i believe that when clay gets
his thing going draymond green gets back
james wiseman gets back i picked the
warriors to win the chip okay but i
can't say enough about how great of a
job monty williams is doing and when we
talk about black coaches and being
leaders of men yes that man shows it
every day chris paul is the
quintessential point guard a hall of
famer phenomenal he's got them playing
mikhail bridges these guys they they can
win it all
i would say brooklyn if kyrie played all
the time because i don't think you can
stop them
but and i've said this on tv
what if there's a game seven
what if it's in brooklyn
and you ain't vaccinated and the mandate
is still in place and you can't play
i don't know if you can overcome his
absence against a quality team
like the phoenix suns or like the
warriors so my answer would be brooklyn
but it's because of the suspect
availability
of kyrie irving yeah and i chose the
warriors to win the championship this
year too so that would mean paul cancer
i'll take the brooklyn nets even though
i chose the warriors to win it all as
well i don't know all right this next
one plays into that too what you just
said about brooklyn stephen a and it's
kind of a fun what if
who's more likely to play a home game
for a new york team first
zion or kyrie i love it
damn
oh my god that's a tough question oh
it's got to be zion right
no
listen man kyrie irving i'd give him 50
million a year the brother spectacular
but it would be one year at a time i
would never pay him a long-term deal
again because he's proven he can't be
trusted he's just listen kyrie works on
his game he works hard all the time but
he does what he wants to do and he don't
want to answer to nobody he want to do
what he want to do can't trust somebody
like that long term can't do that
but zion
zion
looks like he ate an ihop
like no not at all
it's like listen man listen man
i'm not ridiculing he's a kid
he's a superstar talent i love him
personally right
i'm not questioning this injury the
legitimacy of it even though he's been
out for a long time
and i happen to believe just believe
just no inside information just believe
he'd rather be in new york than new
orleans
okay yeah and he's not enamored and that
may have play a role
but you a big boy
and when you you can't work out big boys
get bigger you see who i came in here
with yes
that's a big boy right there
my man juvie that's a big boy okay now
he happens to be big and strong and
he'll work out you see what i'm saying
but god help him if he did it
that's i am
what you doing
i
no i i gotta say kyrie
right now i gotta say
maybe because the mandate might be
lifted right like the pan so you're
saying the pandemic's gotta end for
kyrie to win this what's more likely
yeah as opposed to
zion but zion outlasting the pandemic
and getting traded to getting traded
that's a big boy
that's a big boy my man kendrick perkins
and people on nba countdown
me and my man jaylen rose mike wilbon
mike greenberg they were joking about
how you know zion said somebody brought
him a peloton that was their christmas
gift him i said what about a treadmill
too
i need zion to get in shape so he can
get on the court and remind us of the
superstar talent he can be okay last one
all-time great to win one more
championship
lebron james aaron rodgers
what's more like what's more likely
i'm gonna go with aaron rodgers
i'm gonna go with aaron rodgers i'm very
disappointed you know how i feel he's a
bad man
but that playoff game against san
francisco he was just bad and i was
incredibly disappointed in his
performance didn't like the fact that he
lied about being vaccinated with his
immunized whole
nonsense but he's still a bad brother
and i love him
here's my deal
i don't think aaron rodgers is going any
place but to a contender
if he decides to leave the contender
that is the green bay packers and lebron
lebron
you got
the warriors in your way
and they're younger
you got the phoenix suns in your way
and they're younger and better both of
them are better
have you seen john marant
right have you seen
this kid bane have you seen this kid
jackson
do you know this kid dylan do you see
the athletes
on that memphis grizzly squad
and how they come at you
lebron is 36.
melo's 37.
i think lebron just turned 37 he's 37-36
37 in december but mello's there anthony
davis is perpetually injured
russell westbrook is an extraordinary
talent give him the ball and tell him to
take over he can do that for you ask him
to fit in and run the point god spot no
everything can change give lebron the
ball
let him run the offense when you give it
to russ tell him to attack the basket
don't think about it
but that still don't make you better
than the warriors the sons the grizzlies
and i forget utah either
with donovan mitchell and those boys and
rudy gobert
the path to prosperity
is significantly more difficult for
lebron james
and that was before you turned 36 or 37
whichever hell of one it is i gotta go
with hammer rogers i'd have to agree
with you thanks for the call for being
here i really appreciate it my pleasure
thanks for being here absolutely this is
you are the best thank you sir you're a
great man and i'm happy to see you here
and you know first take every day
stephen a's world on espn plus
you're welcome here love you love the
family man always great to be right back
at you it's mutual that's stephen a
smith right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here